in today's installment of collab week I
am joined by the brilliant and breezy
Louise also known as sprinkleofglitter
and we'll be collaborating through the
medium of painting I would like to pay -
me and you filming a collab ok so it
will be a collab in a code I'm gonna
curl up ok I like that a lot
I'll draw myself look you should draw me
and I'll draw you ok so you just stay
there ok I'm over this you're an actual
artist then well just a little I would
just draw a circle let's do this
oh yeah hands oh yeah yeah I like we
didn't either
that's your hand put a paintbrush every
day I can't wait for you to see what I'm
gonna go this is gonna take so long
today
here's your face okay there we go yeah
that's it it's about right ah my god
okay okay very tall that's lovely
done that's the drawing bit what do we
start with I'm painting yes
okay I've got outside the lines that's
right I think bits I feel like I'm
letting down Charlie is so cool like the
channel laughter you don't have a
different science and you get some pink
imbecille like painting this awful
picture of you I'm perfectly happy with
it
anyone else who doesn't like it can deal
with it that's some thick paint right
there oh Jesus
oh you get the texture I know what my
brain is leaking or something over here
see I watched you take to your skin
quite hard to do skin though I think
this whole project is hard if I'm honest
Wow
I feel bad for myself I just know it's
my methyls oh no like you put a piece of
poo in my mouth first your smiles
what's my off your winning smile I've
given it with the paintbrushes cut out
the middleman that's what I say Charlie
it's working for you clearly right clear
doctrine charlie what color eyes you
have blue or green I have blue eyes
let's say they're green because I'm
really gonna blue let's say that a
Viridian hue this is what like um what's
that one that did those ones the one
that did those one eyes go off this is
what
it like like textured like even the fact
that they are both like he is a painter
and you are painting necessarily a lick
I want to make between this and Van Gogh
I don't think he would mind all art is
art is no I guess so she wanted to be
doing yellow shoes today yeah why not
just let it sort of we could vote like
blood deeper in my mouth and this is
like mustard Depot fun fact did you know
that at this point in the proceedings
one of the cameras stopped recording and
we didn't we didn't realize so skip to
the end here we are explaining
everything we did tada
okay now let's explain everything that
you just missed so I did sort of some
astronomy here our star and the stars
this is trying to be excited but also
maybe shot so this is my hahaha just
here and this is hands on a cup of tea
how do you say that you're gonna do tea
didn't realize it that is what my
favorite part of you is is your glasses
nice beautiful if I was a painting girl
I'd fall in love with you this is
basically exactly what you look like
I've managed to recreate you perfectly
until like looking in the mirror wait
look I mean and also what you missed is
we named it collab attack I didn't
actually notice this when we're filming
a Miss felt collab I did notice a little
anything you didn't say except like oh
no well I'm still proud of it me to
collaborate a we did very I think we did
a good job yay clever yeah thank you for
watching Thank You charlie you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
lovely jubbly thank you very much for
watching and if you'd like to watch the
other two collaboration videos from this
week you know what to do good bye